ALBERT MEYER: We've looked at
independence for two events.
What about when we
have a bunch of events?
Well, in that case
we want to look
at the idea of
mutual independence.
So let's check that out.
I'll say that if I have
n different events,
I'll say that they're mutually
independent, intuitively.
If the probability
that one of them occurs
is unchanged by which other
ones happen to have occurred.
So expressed in conditional
probability, which
is the way to make it precise,
what we're really saying
is that events A1 through An
are mutually independent when
the probability of Ai is equal
to the probability of Ai,
given the intersection
of any of the other
As as long as i is
not one of them.
So take A1, A2, or
A1, A2, A3, and so on.
And A5 is going to
be independent of all
of those other intersections.
If we shift over to the other
definition of independence
that we used for two sets,
in terms of products,
you could say that n sets
are mutually independent when
the probability of the
intersection of any bunch
of them is equal to the product
of the individual probabilities
of the events in
the intersection.
Let's look at an example
of mutual independence.
Maybe the simplest
one is the one
of independent coin flips, which
by definition are independent.
So the idea is that I will
flip a coin a bunch of times.
And I will let Hi be
the event that the ith
time I flip I get a heads.
So if you think about
what's going on,
what happens on
the fifth flip has
nothing to do with what happens
on the first, fourth or seventh
flip.
There's no causal
relationship between the flips
before or after flip five.
Flip five is an isolated
event by itself.
And the fact that there
were a bunch of heads before
or there will be
a bunch of heads
afterward doesn't have any
impact on the probability
that the fifth flip
comes up with a head.
At least that's what we
believe and that's the way
that we would model them.
So what that means,
for example, is
that the probability of
a head on the fifth toss
is equal to the probability of
a head on the fifth toss given
that the first toss was a head
and the fourth toss was a head
and the seventh
toss was not a head.
This is the complement of H7.
So that would just
be an example of one
of the many different
conditional equations that
hold when you have
mutual independence.
Let's look at an example.
Suppose that I flip
a fair coin twice.
Now, the previous definition
didn't require fairness at all
in the coin flipping.
But now I'm going to need it.
So that means that heads and
tails are equally likely.
And suppose I flip
the coin twice.
Well, let H1 be as before,
the event that a head comes up
on the first flip.
And H2, the event that a head
comes up on the second flip.
And let O be the event that
there were an odd number
of heads in the two flips.
Now, I claim that O is
independent of whether or not
there's a head on
the first flip.
That may seem a
little weird because O
depends on both the first
flip and the second flip.
It's whether or not there are
an odd number of heads there,
but nevertheless, I
claim that whether or not
there are an odd
number of heads is
independent of whether or not
the first toss was a head.
Let's just check it using
the official definition.
First of all, O is
the event HT TH.
If I write out Hs and
Ts, a pair of them
for what the results of the
first and second flips were,
you get an odd number of heads
exactly when there's first
a head and then a tail or first
a tail and then a head, which
means that the probability
of O is exactly a half.
Because the other
two outcomes are
TT and HH, which is when you
have an even number of heads.
Now, O into section
H1 is saying that you
have an odd number of heads
and the first toss is a head.
The only outcome that
fits that description
is HT, which means that--
and the probability of HT
is a quarter-- so the
probability of O intersection
H1 is a quarter.
O into section H1 is
just a peculiar way
of saying you got a head
and then you got a tail.
So that means that the
probability of O intersection
H1 is a quarter.
And of course, that's equal
to the probability of O,
which we decided was a half,
and the probability of H1,
which of course is
a half, because we
said the coin was fair.
So I've verified the condition
for the independence of O
and H1, and therefore, I'm done.
But the weird
thing to notice now
is that if you look at O, H1,
and H2, the three of them,
they are not
mutually independent.
Because in fact, if you
know any two of them
you can figure out
what the third one was.
But just explicitly in terms
of conditional probabilities,
the probability of there
being an odd number of heads,
given that the first
toss was a head
and the second toss
was a head, is 0,
because once you
know H1 and H2 you
know exactly how many
heads there were.
There were two.
And that's not odd.
So the probability of odd
given H1 intersection H2
is 0, which is not equal to the
probability of odd by itself,
which was a half.
So the three of them
are not independent.
They're not mutually
independent,
even though any two of them
are because O and H1 are.
And obviously O and
H2 are by symmetry.
And H1 and H2 to
are coin tosses,
and they're independent.
So that leads us to the general
idea of k-way independence.
And an example would be if
you flip a fair coin k times,
let Hi be whether or not
there's a head on the ith flip.
And you let O, again,
be whether or not
there are an odd
number of heads.
And by the same
argument, you can
verify that any set
of k of these events
are mutually independent.
But if you give me all k plus 1,
then they are not independent.
In fact, any k of them will
determine the k plus first one.
But any k among themselves
will be mutually independent.
So that's why this notion of how
independent a bunch of sets are
comes up, and this
is how to count it.
So in general, events A1 through
an arbitrary set of events
are k-way independent
if any k of them
are mutually independent.
Pairwise, then, is just the
case of two way independence.
And what we saw was the
example that with k coin
flips the events
odd and the outcomes
of head or not on H1 through
Hk are k-way independent,
but not k plus one
way independent.
By the way, now
that we understand
what k-way independence is,
mutual independence of n sets
is simply n-way independence.
But I just wanted to
close with the remark
that checking with n events
are mutually independent
means that you
actually have to check
all the intersections
equaling the products
of the individual events
in the intersection.
So that there are two to
the n possible collections
of subsets of A1
through An and you
have to check for each of
them, that the intersection
of those ones that you chose
is equal to the product
of their probabilities.
But of course, you don't need
to check the empty selection.
And you don't need to
check the single [? set ?],
so you just have to
check the 2 to the n
equations corresponding
to all the subsets of size
more than one.
So it's 2 to the n minus n
plus 1 equations to check.
So in general, it's
not going to be
easy to verify mutual
independence by doing
this kind of a calculation.
And you usually
arrive at it really
by assumption most of the time.